ce soir le plan orsec a été déclenché
dans quatre départements les vosges la
marne la haute-marne et la meurthe et
moselle
mais cette tempête cette tempête
exceptionnelle à d'abord touché l'ouest
de la france la bretagne et la normandie
où neuf personnes ont trouvé la mort
d'importants dégâts matériels sont
également à déplorer
des images impressionnantes commentée
par dominique dumas la normandie touché
de plein fouet par la tornade dans tous
les départements normands des dizaines
de toits ont été arrachés provoquant de
nombreux dégâts matériels
ce matin trois personnes ont été
blessées dans l'effondrement d'une
maison à colleville dans le calvados les
arbres par dizaines en tombant sur les
chaussées ont causé de nombreux
accidents faisant au moins une dizaine
de blessés
la circulation devrait être en partie
rétablie sur les grands axes mais les
problèmes demeurent sur les routes
secondaires
on déplore jusqu'à ce soir cinq victimes
deux hier dans le calvados
aujourd'hui un homme de 70 ans à
cricqueboeuf est une jeune femme a cool
20 une femme de 90 ans également été
découvertes ce soir sans vie dans les
décombres de sa maison de saint lô selon
les secteurs un foyer sur deux ou sur
trois étaient privés d'électricité en
fin d'après midi le trafic sncf devrait
reprendre demain lundi les plages
normandes elle aussi offrait un aspect
de désolation la bretagne déjà éprouvée
par la marée noire paie également un
lourd tribut à la tempête
quatre morts dans un accident sur la
voie express rennes saint brieuc à cause
de la chute d'un arbre
des dizaines de toitures ont été
arrachées comme ici dans cette maison de
retraite de bégard dans les côtes
d'armor un département parmi les plus
touchés en bretagne
ce soir le gouvernement envoie trois
mille hommes pour aider les bretons
certaines équipes qui devaient se rendre
dans le grand ouest ont été bloqués à
cause de la tempête vous pouvez plus
dégarnir certains départements nous
devons faire face sur beaucoup de fronts
à la fois la tempête et la pollution
maritime
un nouveau coup de vent est prévu pour
cette nuit ce qui risque encore
d'aggraver la situation
de nombreuses routes étant coupées par
les inondations de ces dernières 24
heures